we're looking into disappearances some
recent others dating back several years
the pattern is disturbing
I transferred from missing persons very
whole we studied your cases at the
academy they date back that far yeah
you're up there with the legends I can't
keep covering for you doesn't matter who
you are tell her I think it's the
falling of snow that's sex they kill her
off then who does he leave the snowman
for building snowmen cutting things up
into little pieces that's what a child
does to stablish order a call just came
in there's another missing woman
we got the missing persons call I was
missing
Sylvia autism I'm Sylvia artisan why
would someone report you missing
[Music]
they reported a missing before he killed
her I don't want a word of this to be
legally
[Music]
was a suicide and a story he sure he was
alone
where's Katrina
I will see if this it's personal
[Music]
he was watching us the whole time he's
playing games
I could save them you know give you all
the clothes and everything
you
you